à quoi ressemblera ton téléphone dans le
futur lorsqu'on les a imaginé en 1947
on se doutait sûrement pas ouah autant
raison je vous propose donc de faire
comme eux de voir quels sont les projets
en cours ainsi que l'état actuel de la
science afin de deviner à quoi
ressembleront les téléphones du futur et
cette vidéo est sponsorisé par nord le
pn les téléphones seront qu'il tousse
payable vous rappelez vous de la folie
qu'il y a eu quand les premiers
téléphones pliable ont été annoncés les
artistes les voyait déjà toutes les
sauces des téléphones à clapet à ceux
qui se déplie en tablette
un an après les premiers modèles vendus
qu'en est il chez samsung avec galaxie
fold c'est pas fameux
les premiers modèles étaient
catastrophiques on pouvait rayer l'écran
avec un ongle la charnière grâce à la
moindre poussière et surtout le pi
finissait par se sentir au toucher et
marquer l'écran c'est aussi flippant que
moche ils ont réussi à faire une version
2 qui corrige une partie de ces défauts
mais les ventes ne décollent pas le
premier problème c'est le prix plus de
2000 euros en moyenne
et c'est pas juste par vénalité des
constructeurs le prix des composants la
galaxie fold est d'environ 630 dollars
soit presque le double d'un smartphone
haut de gamme de la marque un prix
colossal pourtant insuffisant pour
rembourser les 130 millions $
d'investissement car non un smartphone
ne s'ouvre pas comme un livre et quelque
chose d' incompatible et de gênant avec
ce design c'est pour ça que la prochaine
génération de téléphone pliable sera
bien différente
vous ne rêvez pas c'est sans trucage
le x 21 dopo et le relais bol des tcl
sont deux prototypes de téléphones qui
donne l'impression de devenir des
tablettes que simple pression sur un
bouton le tour de magie
c'est simplement d'enrouler l'écran pas
de figure disgracieuses ici
pression naturelle voilà peut être un
moyen de sauver les de téléphone pliable
du cimetière des projets abandonnés les
téléphones seront ils tous transparents
et si votre futur téléphone était le
même que tony stark dans iron man ou
comme les écrans transparents de
minority report
il y a des centaines de concept art qui
rêvent de la même chose mais est ce
réellement possible d'avoir un téléphone
transparent des entreprises travaillent
déjà dessus
c'est notamment le cas de samsung qui a
commencé à déposer plainte de brevets en
2013 en soit les téléviseurs transparent
existe depuis quelques années qu'est ce
qui empêcherait de faire pareil a
beaucoup de choses en fait
ces télévisions repose sur un socle où
toute l'électronique non transparentes
et contenus un téléphone ne peut pas se
permettre cela à la limite un téléphone
à clapet une phase transparente et
l'autre électronique mais on veut un
vrai truc comme les concepts art
eh bien figurez vous que ça pourrait
être possible on sait déjà faire des
câbles transparent et des batteries
transparente appliquer cette technologie
à tous les éléments et on est bon sauf
que si vous demandez à une salle pleine
de gens s'ils veulent avoir un
smartphone à écran transparent
je parie que leur réponse serait bien
sûr j'en veux un mais réellement combien
de ces personnes seraient prêts à en
acheter un au prix fort
oui c'est stylé mais ça ne justifie pas
un achat il faut aussi prendre en compte
l'affichage si vous avez déjà du mal à
lire sur votre écran en plein jour vous
n'avez plus qu'à rendre l'écran
transparent pour le rendre inutilisable
au moindre rayon de soleil
heureusement on est capable de changer
la teinte du vert à la demande et ainsi
de rendre le vert plus foncé pour mieux
voir mais dans ce cas c'est quoi
l'intérêt d'avoir un écran transparent
cette question de la luminosité c'est ce
qui ruine beaucoup de projets d'écran
style et prônons le secret' un bracelet
qui permet de transformer votre poignet
en téléphone en quelques jours c'est le
buzz avec plus de 5 millions de vues
malheureusement ça n'existe pas c'est
juste un concept des experts se sont
projetés sur sa faisabilité et ça serait
illisible en plein jour donc tu es dans
l'os pareil pour les téléphones hologram
on rêve tous de parler à ses potes comme
dans star wars mais ça ne marcherait pas
la lumière du jour
raide quand même essayé avec l'hydrogène
one
enfin du moins sur papier ça ressemblait
plus à un écran de nintendo 3ds
pour ce qui est des hologrammes qui
sortent vraiment de l'écran c'est déjà
le faire avec une petite pyramide posé
sur l'écran et des vidéos youtube fait
pénalement pour ça pourquoi la réalité
toujours décevante les téléphones
auront-ils des batteries de 100 heures
la batterie voilà souvent le gourou
problème des téléphones
on a l'impression de passer sa vie à
recharger c'est vrai chaque année on y
passe plus de 20000 minutes
comment régler ce problème sans devoir
trimballer cette immonde téléphone
energizer à 50 jours de batterie
l'entorse au poignet au verte le
principal problème avec nos batteries
c'est qu'elles sont physiquement et
chimiquement limitez pas augmenter la
densité de stockage indéfiniment une
batterie de 200 heures ça peut pas
exister pour trouver une autre solution
on peut déjà commencer par augmenter la
vitesse de recharge pour ça les
batteries au graphène sont les plus
prometteuses
des chercheurs du mi6 ont réussi une
percée en superposant deux couches de
graphène dan atome d'épaisseur à un
angle très précis de 1,1 degré avec un
dopage d'électrons ils ont réussi à
rendre le graphène supraconducteurs dit
plus simplement votre téléphone se
chargent instantanément cependant il va
falloir encore attendre au moins 5 ans
avant que cette technologie soit
commercialisé on n'a pas encore de
moyens de produire ça de façon
industrielle c'est que pour des petites
quantités et c'est très cher samsung et
cei et avec des méthodes plus simples
avec débit de graphène ils ont réussi
une recharge complète en 12 minutes
contre une heure en moyenne
une autre piste pour les batteries
serait de les rendre plus souples grâce
à la mousse de métal
on commence par un substrat en mousse de
cuivre puis en utilisant un processus de
galvanoplastie la mousse est enduite de
la note d'anti monnyer de cuivre puis
recouvert d'un électrolytes à l'état
solide et d'une suspension cathodique
d'auxi de lithium et de cobalt
grâce à ça on peut créer une batterie de
la forme que l'on veut et ça ça risque
d'être très utile pour les objets
connectés ont une super batterie c'est
bien mais ça nous oblige quand même à
brancher des fils
comment pourrait-on s'en passer la
technologie
existe depuis 2008 mais ce n'est pas
fiable avec de simplement apple et son
mec safe ont réussi à rendre cette
technologie aussi tendance que pratique
tu le pause
il sait menthe et sa recharge cool mais
on peut encore aller plus loin par
exemple sonic énergie qui propose de se
servir des ultrasons pour fournir de
l'électricité
le concept marche en deux parties la
première est l'émetteur qui transmet un
son ultra haute fréquence qui est
imperceptible à l'oreille humaine
secondes
le récepteur fonctionne comme un
microphone en captant les ondes
ultrasonores et convertissant l'énergie
acoustique en énergie électrique
les récepteurs peuvent être rechargées
pendant qu'ils sont statiques ou en
mouvement
ainsi l'utilisateur peut se déplacer
tout en rechargeant son téléphone
cependant comme l'a montré un youtuber
tech pour le moment c'est pas très
efficace est la portée du signal est pas
top
les téléphones perdre ont-ils lors
dernier bouton comme on l'a vu la
recharge électrique sans fil va sûrement
bientôt rendre obsolète le dernier port
de notre téléphone
on ne fera plus ce geste ni pour charger
ses données y avant de se coucher le
port jack a déjà disparu grâce aux
progrès du bluetooth le bouton home et
maintenant pacte il que reste t'il d'eau
qui a retiré pour d'avoir qu'un écran
d'abord la caméra frontale pour corps
visible ici sur iphone on peut le cacher
sous l'écran comme un fait est 2e avec
son à 20 qui vient de sortir chez
youtube earth est contestée ça marche
parfaitement ensuite les trous des
enceintes pour ça la solution cd en
simple piézoélectriques ici c'est les
micros des formations des matériaux qui
vont créer le saut ce qui permet de le
diffuser sur du plastique ou dans les
autres ton crâne et comme ça ça fait un
peu flipper mais des écouteurs à
diffusion osseuse ça existe depuis
longtemps
on pourrait les implémenter dans le haut
du téléphone pour écouter ses appels en
toute discrétion un port oublier c'est
celui de la carte sim
disons le ça ne sert absolument plus à
rien avec la téléphonie ip on pourrait
s'en passer pour gagner de la place et
de l'été en chiite et mais bon
et allegro société ne veulent pas perdre
ce marché juteux
reste enfin les boutons latéraux et pour
sa vie voit déjà trouvé une solution
avec son apex 2019 au lieu des boutons
physiques
il utilise des sortes de petits boutons
tactiles et des capteurs de pression sur
le côté de l'écran le truc c'est que les
consommateurs on n'adhère pas forcément
on l'a vu avec les fameux téléphone
écran sans bord les borderless alors ça
marche c'est beau c'est pas pratique
en plus d'augmenter les coûts de réduire
l'originalité du design entre
constructeurs de ne pas être agréable à
l'utilisation à cause des poisses manip
ses téléphones se sont avérées
extrêmement fragile imaginez les coûts
de sav pour les constructeurs
alors on peut toujours régler le
problème mais quel intérêt de se dire
borderless si on doit le protéger avec
une coque rinsch annoncé par qui
sponsorise cette vidéo reste que oui on
se dirige vers des téléphones mono
design avec un écran comme ça
l'interface les téléphones sont-ils
modulaire produire un téléphone ça
pollue bout actuellement les pays comme
le congo ou la chine sont prêts a
contaminé des milliers de gens pour
récupérer quelques tonnes de métal
nécessaires à nos téléphones
rien qu'un iphone ix produire à 93 kg de
co2 durant sa vie quand on multiplie sa
part les 70 millions d'unités on arrive
à la même pollution que 43 millions de
voitures pendant un an
c'est un désastre écologique sans
compter qu'avec ces matériaux de plus en
plus rare et non recyclés les prix
flambent
il finira par devenir nécessaire d'avoir
un téléphone qui arrive à résoudre ce
problème
un des premiers à avoir essayé c'est
google avec son projet de téléphone
modulaire haras ça consistait en un
écran et quelques composants internes
fixer ensemble sur lequel on pouvait
rajouter des modules supplémentaires
avec hara je pourrais choisir si je veux
une caméra soit très puissante ou soit
qui fait le minimum
ça sera selon mes besoins et mon budget
c'est un module est cassée obsolète jeu
pourrait ainsi facilement le remplacer
sans avoir besoin de me déplacer dans un
magasin où on me dira encore une
millième fois qu'il faudra changer tout
mon téléphone
cependant si le projet était en bonne
voie tout d'un coup on a appris qu'il
était annulé
est ce la faute du capitalisme à ses
constructeurs qui veulent nous vendre
toujours
de téléphone quitte à détruire la
planète pas en fait non le problème
c'est nous d'autres projets comme fun
blocks où le fair phone ont beau ne pas
être tenus par les gaffes à ils ont
connu le même destin car à leurs fans
étaient pourtant moins utopique
un simple téléphone construit pour qu'on
puisse le réparer soi-même pas de module
compliqué juste un téléphone
écolo est simple à comprendre il n'a été
vendu qu'à 125 mille exemplaires en deux
ans la raison de cet échec
vous le savez au fond de vous on veut le
dernier téléphone à la mode
et même si ça vous intéresse pas au fond
c'est comme un pc fixe vous pourriez
leur gré pendant 20 ans mais vous le
faites pas psychologiquement c'est relou
de vérifier la compatibilité de chaque
composant alors on préfère tout changer
jusqu au boîtier l' envie de repartir à
zéro
nice est clean la plupart des gens n'ont
aucun intérêt pour la modularité des
fonctions principales
ils s'attendent juste à qu'elles soient
présentes et fonctionnel dira l'ancien
directeur du projet aha on peut
s'imaginer qu'avec la raréfaction des
terres rares et la flambée de leurs prix
que les entreprises sont bien un jour
obligé de s'y remettre la fin des
téléphones la cij et est déjà une
réalité dans un futur proche on pourra
télécharger à 1 térabit de seconde
soixante mille heures de films netflix
en une minute de quoi s'occuper toute
une vie cette puissance rendra inutile
le fait de posséder un gros processeur
la puissance de calcul pourra être mise
dans le cloud l'idée de jouer à un jeu
vidéo en streaming
aujourd'hui bon ça plaît pas trop mais
ça finira forcément par devenir la norme
né alors l'idée que le téléphone du
futur n'existera tout simplement plus et
des gens réfléchissent déjà à quoi ça va
ressembler dans futurama il y à l'iphone
qui permet de téléphoner directement
dans son oeil
google avait essayé mais ça a échoué
avec google glace le projet rendu public
en 2012 avec une vidéo a fan 2 millions
de vues qui est aujourd'hui en ont
répertorié
pourtant si on regarde cette vidéo est
forcément ip ses lunettes ont l'air de
littéralement changé notre vie le rêve
d'un monde en réalité augmentée mais ça
c'est la théorie dans la pratique on a
une paire de lunettes à peine capable de
faire mieux qu'un smartphone avec une
mauvaise autonomie
un prix de 1500 $ et un look ou
objectivement moche sans compter la
crainte d'atteinte à la vie privée qui
ont conduit à des bannissements par les
autorités le problème des google glace
et que la technologie d'aujourd'hui
n'offrent tout simplement rien que les
gens ordinaires veulent vraiment
peut-être qu'avec un petit coup de pouce
technologique on pourra rallier les gens
wind connectés et pour ça il y annonce
vocale c'est pas normés pernaut vous
avez vu vous avez eu peur on croirait
presque voir des lunettes normales mais
niveau fonctionnalités c'est un bond en
avant depuis les google classe cette
fois ci pas de caméras mais la
possibilité de contrôler un bon nombre
d'applications de recevoir des messages
d'y répondre d'utiliser alexa et même de
commander des beurs s'en sortir son
téléphone un autre projet similaire avec
bosch ce qu'il faut il faudra les frigos
peut utiliser le guidage gps gérer sa
liste de courses ou suivre une recette
de cuisine et qu'on voit tout ça on peut
se demander si on ne pourrait pas
carrément retiré les montures et passer
directement aux lentilles connectés non
non vous ne rêvez pas ça arrive avec
mojo ils sont premiers prototypes la
première utilité
c'est évidemment de courir et l'abus des
gens mais ce qui nous intéresse nous
c'est sa capacité à transformer l'oeil
en interface entre l'homme et la machine
pour le moment ce n'est encore limité
mais on retrouve quelques affichages
comme nos pulsations par minute où la
vitesse à laquelle on marche
dit comme ça ça semble pas exceptionnel
mais pour quand même se rappeler que ça
tient dans une toute petite lentille sur
votre oeil avec des pixels plus petites
qu'un grain de sable le futur décidément
est excitant le futur des téléphones
sera aussi un besoin de sécurité et
justement on est ravi de faire cette
vidéo en partenariat avec norvez pn qui
aident à produire plein de contenus
scientifiques sur le sujet dans vpn vous
connaissez si vous avez netflix à vous
permet de regarder les catalogues des
autres pays
ça va faire croire aux serveurs que vous
êtes dans un autre endroit du monde donc
fini les blocages ce contenu n'est pas
accessible dans votre région c'est
terminé mais nord dpn c'est aussi la
sécurité en passant tu t'es donné dans
un filtre un serveur tampon qui va
anonymisées et sécuriser votre
navigation
un cryptage puissant des flux de données
pour que personne ne les interceptent
des bloqueurs de publicité et de
malwares qui empêche à coeur et
gouvernement de vous surveiller des mots
de passe en crypté avec les plus
puissants algorithmes
sur une garantie qu'aucune de vos
données ne soient gardés par la société
alors les amis on a pensé à vous avec
une offre spéciale de noël mois 68% sur
north dpn pendant deux ans et recevez
quatre mois offerts supplémentaire c'est
sur notre lien en descriptions avec le
code promo science trash
ça a été un plaisir pour nous de vous
faire cette vidéo avec mon ancien
étudiant georges
on remercie aussi les monteurs fils bois
quoi ils ont fait un travail incroyable
on se retrouve très vite à bientôt ciao